[Music]
hey kids
wow you've got quite a spread here so
too much
stand down Greg look at this
a mysterious disturbance recently took
place in the town of Madison Delaware
creatures come alive from the original
manuscripts the doll Stein the book what
book
it's a goosebumps buck it's locked
Oh what did you do it's time to make
Halloween
you get the string
we're living a goosebumps story right
now I hear it's a real scream
Halloween is alive I know it's my
favorite holiday - you're gonna need
some serious therapy after this that
book is the only thing we have to end
this
let's go
[Music]
someone's gonna win a costume contest
goosebumps Halloween
all these gummy bears coming soon
you